[Musique]
avec vous Hélène Fred bonjour Hélène
bonjour Pauline on va revenir bien sûr
avec vous sur l'un des titres du journal
ce matin l'explosion de domicile hier
dans un village polonais tout près de la
frontière avec l'Ukraine l'explosion qui
a fait deux morts et provoqué par un
projectile de fabrication russe c'est ce
que dit en tout cas le ministère
polonais des Affaires étrangères et le
président polonais André a déclaré
n'avoir aucune preuve sur qui attiré ses
missiles et indiqué qu'une enquête était
en cours mais la version anglaise du
gratuit Métro affirme déjà que des
missiles russes ont touché la Pologne et
qu'il s'agit là de l'escalade de la
guerre de Poutine après je peux spolita
quotidien polonais appelle en tout cas à
l'union sacrée face à ce qu'il présente
je cite comme une épreuve de maturité de
responsabilité une épreuve de sagesse et
de courage pour la Pologne face à la
violation de notre territoire nous
devons être unis pour que la menace de
la guerre ne plane plus sur l'Europe
nous sommes membres de que et de l'OTAN
nous n'avons rien à craindre à cette le
journal
Facte autre quotidien en polonais Hélène
s'interroge lui sur ce qui est c'est
réellement passé hier en Pologne cette
frappe de missile si les confirmé que
ces missiles sont russes
signifient-elles une attaque armée
contre la Pologne doit-on s'attendre à
une nouvelle escalade de la part d'une
Russie exaspérée par la perteuse récente
de Carson pour le journal si et
seulement si cela était confirmé alors
les alliés de la Pologne devrait être
obligatoirement lui venir en aide
conformément voler vous l'avez dit au
disposition des articles quatre et cinq
du traité de l'OTAN un tel scénario
reste néanmoins peu probable d'après le
gardien le quotidien britannique estime
que l'incident d'hier est sans doute en
deçà du seuil nécessaire pour déclencher
une action collective de l'OTAN contre
la Russie même si les risques
d'affrontements ne peuvent pas être
totalement écartées le spectre d'une
guerre généralisée a évoqué enfin dans
ce dessin de Ramsès publié par le site
cartoon
qui montre on le voit à missile tirer
depuis le char de Vladimir Poutine
pourrait à missile qui déclencherait
éventuellement une troisième guerre
mondiale beaucoup de réactions également
ce matin Hélène on en parlait dans le
journal à l'annonce de la candidature de
donner de Donald Trump à la
présidentielle américaine de 2024
Pauline c'est que cette annonce ne
suscite pas un enthousiasme débridé y
compris dans le camp républicain non nos
titres simplement la très conservatrice
National Review en paraphrasant le très
français Voltaire le philosophe des
Lumières qui avait assisté une fois à
une orgie une fois c'était une
expérience deux fois c'est pervers
l'Amérique mérite mieux que Donald Trump
single de son côté le New York Times en
accusant l'ex-président de cette relancé
dans une nouvelle campagne avec la même
laideur les mêmes mensonges et le même
chaos je cite que la précédente à cette
différence que celle qui a débuté cette
nuit poserait un danger encore plus
grand pour la démocratie américaine
Trump candidat envers et contre tous ou
presque le Washington Post ne voit que
deux explications à cela sont désir de
vengeance et sa volonté d'échapper au
poursuites lancer contre lui en
l'absence d'un carcération ou
d'inhumation et peut-être même dans ce
seul cas il était inévitable que de donc
Trump Brig un nouveau mandat c'est le
journal Donald Trump peut qu'on retrouve
enfin dans ce dessin de davebron publié
sur Twitter ordonnante à l'éléphant
républicain ou du moins ce qu'il en
reste de se lancer à l'assaut de la
Maison Blanche beaucoup de critiques
toujours Hélène sur le Mondial de footo
au Qatar à quatre jours maintenant du
match d'ouverture ce sera dimanche elle
est tempête de protestation provoquée
par ce Mondial de foot interpelle
l'équipe qui évoque l'errance d'Arabie
un titre assez poétique pour une réalité
qu'il est beaucoup moins même si le
quotidien français tient à évoqué ce
matin la fierté du monde arabe d'avoir
réussi à décrocher sa coupe du monde en
croire le journal les critiques contre
la Coupe du Monde du
Qatar aurait en réalité soudée toute la
péninsule arabique qui réplique aux
critiques ont renvoyant l'Occident je
cite à son indignation sélective une
indignation que risque en tout cas
d'alimenter encore un peu plus ses
révélations de nouveau ce matin du
gardien qui fait état du témoignage d'un
ressortissant du Qatar actuellement
réfugiés aux États-Unis celui-ci affirme
que des homosexuels catharris se sont
vues promettre par les autorités d'être
exemptées de peine de prison et même de
torture physique à condition de dénoncer
d'autres homosexuels on ne se quitte pas
là dessus Hélène avant de vous dire à
tout à l'heure Pauline et parce que je
connais votre goût pour les chaussures
moches je vous propose de jeter un style
au Figaro litière à préciser que non ce
n'est pas un canular le journal rapporte
que des sandales ayant appartenu à feu
Steve Jobs l'ancien patron d'Apple et
bien que cette paire de godasses a été
vendue près de 200000 euros garder les
vôtres bien précieusement on ne sait
jamais ma vengeance
terrible Hélène à tout à l'heure dans
Paris direct